Let's create a weather provider class within the
data package. We'll have it extend content provider. [SOUND]
You can have the required method by heading
Ctrl+I once more. Content providers implement functionality based upon
the URI's. Each URI type is tied to
an integer constant. Our content provider will implement five
different types of URI's. Each one of these
URI's will be used for different types of queries.
For now, let's just add these constants into our weather provider class.
Android provides a URI matcher class to help
match URI's to our integer constants. It provides
for an expression syntax to match various URI's.
Now these are just examples. You're going to have
to implement one of these very soon. Note,
that there are two wildcards. The pound sign
is used to match a number, while a star is used to match a string. Using this,
you can very, very easily match any of the URI's
that we would want to pass in to our content provider.